people take being censored on instagram
or twit so personally like they think
it's such a personal vendetta there's
this like you know i mean comedians i
make fun of them all the time like i've
been shadow banned like someone at
twitter
doesn't like me it's just like or
someone at instagram like they too it's
like i don't think it i don't that's not
it doesn't work that way by the way
all that is that stuff is i'm people
will go crazy when i say this that stuff
is kind of nonsense there's like it's
not that stuff generally there aren't
people at these companies like dude you
have 20 000 followers no one thinks
you're changing the course of history
with your people people who come out are
like oh
it's
it's not that's not happening that's not
how those things work there aren't
people these companies you're exactly
right there are people these companies
they're going like this person in you
know
wherever with 18 000 followers we have
to make sure that you know their stuff
isn't seen by as many people as it just
doesn't it doesn't work that way but
there are rules of course
which is i remember there's this it's
called the tata top and it is a
it is a
the key i don't know this rule it's a
big well it's a it's a uh it's a bikini
that
is boobs and has nipples so you're
wearing it has nipples if you look on
the bikini but they're like uh
airbrushed on i get it so it's like if
you look real quick it's just like kind
of fun you know looks like you're naked
kind for a second hilarious hilarious
so funny that's why i get paid the big
bucks
okay it's a bikini top whatever so i
posted in store and the robot or whoever
is calling through right the robot yeah
the robot the algorithm but the
algorithms like boobs but algorithms are
different right algorithm is is the
curated
um no there are multiple algorithms out
there are multiple algorithms one of the
algorithms is used to go look through
pictures and go oh this is this
community a robot this is a spider
program it's a it's a robot that that am
i intimidating you with my knowledge it
was pretty impressive spider-proof
brighter program pretty good okay i
think pretty impressive
good use um when you repost something
instagram or twitter or one of these
platforms there was code that whips
through it especially if it's a photo or
video and like is this you know content
okay or not
or is it nudity or is it whatever do we
need to put something in front of it do
we need to prevent it from being posted
et cetera that's one of the algorithms
these are humans that's a robot that's a
robot that makes a first pass at like
hey can't post that it's nudity and i
think people are
you know it's interesting because people
like robots are gonna take over next
it's like they're so dumb
right now and if they don't know the
difference between a naked woman and a
woman in a tata top which that is i
remember because when i did this robot
um built this robot for my last special
and had to talk to all these robotics
people forever and ever which is really
fun they're great at
conversation hilarious yeah i love
talking to other humans i have decided
the reason it is going to take so long
for robots to be able to have any kind
of human emotion or be able to have
emotion on their faces because robots
are being built
people don't who don't have that but the
the point that i'm making is oh i was
told uh by this amazing roboticist that
robots will never be able to
essentially be equate to humans or be
trustworthy until they can tell the
difference between a husky and a wolf
that was this person because that was
this person's
that's what it boiled down to because
the point was
they look the same to a robot
but a human can feel the difference
do you know what i mean i think that's
nonsense that's insane that's totally
that's like the craziest most incorrect
thing i've ever heard maybe this guy
didn't work there
the robotics was there also they wear
chick-fil-a uniforms right i've been the
guy at the door
i'll tell you when we're gonna know
when you see that husky over there i
know that's a husky
named biff
yeah no i don't think that i mean like i
don't think that's a good wolves and
huskies look it's like for the auto
drive no i get what you're saying it's
just no if i just explain it more i feel
like you'll agree with me
yeah i can see where this is going
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you